6 24 on your wednesday morning so a  state trooper in colorado went on tape  to make sure that his message about  safety and super windy driving  conditions  stuck  if you don't have to drive  don't  and if you are behind the wheel  understand that these gusts  can push into another lane  or even push you over  right now  anything not strapped down  has a chance of flying away forever  so make sure you're prepared and  keep everything grounded  well i would say hats off to trooper  lewis but it looks like hats on would  probably be more appropriate but thank  you to the colorado state patrol for  sharing the message and it is a serious  one buckle up drive carefully please put  down that phone now if there's something  driving you crazy the email address  traffic 8 8newsnow.com